the movement is so we can get the 47s
back here ready to bring up for Phase
two once you get eyes on Shaw oh I'm
bringing up tomorrow night's new guy
presentation to 1400 today so that all
may revel and partake lot of moving
parts all right oh hey surly come on
peanut butter chocolate that's great
flavor soon hey don't know anyways no
see whiskey doesn't mix well with ice
cream I needed how you hate it yes
either way a fat teenage girl what are
you Bridget Jones really name calling is
that we're doing ya mean airstrip know
anybody ask you got that look get away
from me ask my puppet imagine me ice
cream cook cool nobody gets ice cream
that was awesome the window we're going
out I'll look at her vagina kids my note
I like you too Olaf did Elsa build you
yeah why do you know where she is yeah
why do you think you could show us the
way yeah why how does this work ow stop
it Sven try and focus here yeah why I'll
tell you why we need Elsa to bring back
summer summer oh I don't know why but
I've always loved the idea of summer
time to put on all that comes to okay
right that's actually a good point it
makes a lot of sense and it's better to
keep it real how whether this be real
you know that keep it real yeah okay ah
here we go please how do you say freeze
freeze freeze okay you know what it is
you know moving your top lip that much I
move my top lip so doesn't come out stir
you get upset freeze Ruth just shoot
shoot shoot okay see you pronounce
everything I got you you ready
touch